salut à tous je m'appelle christophe et
j'anime la chronique politique une
chaîne au nom un peu random mais qui au
moins a le mérite d'être clair ici on va
parler politique
et puisqu'on parle politique quelle
orientation pour cette chaîne eh bien
elle est en lien avec mon parcours j'ai
milité décennies à l'extrême gauche
avant de me décaler vers la droite
plusieurs choses ont joué l'ouverture
d'esprit progressive qui vient avec
l'âge également j'ai rencontré des
personnes formées à la science politique
ce qui m'a ouvert des horizons moins
manichéen que les lectures militante
et puis j'ai milité à la période où sont
apparus les théories les revendications
post moderne et multiculturelle lgbt y
anticipé et théorie du genre racialiste
c est devant ses croyances sectaires se
prenant pour des vérités révélées
j'ai fini par conclure que si c'était ça
le progrès eh bien il valait peut-être
mieux s'en tenir éloigné ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui en réaction je suis très
à droite sur pas mal de sujets liés aux
questions sociétales et à l'immigration
et pour me définir je reprendrai à peu
de choses près l'autodéfinition du
sociologue année ou conservateur daniel
bell je suis social en économie libérale
en politique et conservateurs dans le
domaine de la culture des valeurs de
l'identité
pour compléter le tableau j'ajouterai
que je suis de tendance décroissante
dans le domaine de l'écologie et du coup
sur cette chaîne vous trouverez
plusieurs formats principaux d'abord des
vidéos pouvant intéresser tout le monde
il s'agit des vidéos historiques de
synthèse d'actualité ou encore de
présentation de concepts et des idées
venant de tout le spectre politique
et puis des vidéos plus personnel
d'opinion d'analysé et de critique
souvent de la gauche actuelle et qui la
feront peut-être grincer des dents les
moins adroite d'entre vous le tout à
raison de une à trois vidéos par mois
selon la complexité des sujets traités
et si ce programme vous intéresse et
bien je vous invite à vous abonner à la
chaîne et à en partager les vidéos et
sur ce il ne me reste plus qu'à vous
dire à la prochaine